[Music]
this pond
is the only home this fish has ever
known
but lately it's gotten crowded and food
is scarce luckily it has an option
many don't as a walking catfish
it can dance its way out of the water
and on to bigger and better things
however it faces many challenges on its
terrestrial journey it's now in danger
of suffocating
drying up suffering physical damage from
rough terrain
and being hunted by land predators
we think of fish as completely aquatic
animals
but the walking catfish is just one of
hundreds of fish species
that are actually amphibious meaning
that they possess
adaptations that enable them to survive
on land
fish amphibiousness is a spectrum
at one end are species like the mosquito
fish
that'll only move on land when forced
and at the other end
are species like mud skippers that
nonchalantly hop around mud flats
for days at a time but why do fish
make the exodus from water to land and
how do they
cope with this drastic transition
if temperatures get too high for the
mangrove
rivulus in the shallow tropical pools it
inhabits
it'll flip itself onto a bank and cool
off
in the shade during the dry period it
can survive for two months
out of the water by staying in moist
environments
meanwhile the eel catfish makes its
onshore voyage
to satisfy its hearty craving for
beetles
and for others the terrestrial draw is
more ritualistic
every year under the cover of night
masses of
california grunion flop their way onto
sandy beaches
where females deposit thousands of eggs
into the sand
before re-entering the ocean underwater
fish breathe with gills which are
feathery organs
packed with blood vessels that absorb
dissolved oxygen
from the water but in the open air their
gills collapse
and are rendered useless so amphibious
fishes need
other ways to breathe the armored
catfish's stomach
is packed with blood vessels so it can
gulp down
air and breathe through its stomach
lining
and lungfish being related to the
ancestors of
all tetrapods or four limbed vertebrates
are equipped with true lungs they'll
actually
drown if they're kept under water too
long
fish have thin permeable skin that
allows for essential compounds
to diffuse into and out of their bodies
while they're underwater
but this works against them on land as
their bodily moisture
diffuses into the air to dodge
dehydration
mud skippers roll in the mud like
puppies
but the lungfish takes the cake the
rivers it inhabits
disappear during dry seasons so it
buries itself in the earth
and coats its body in a mucous cocoon
it can survive like this for years until
being resuscitated by the next big
rainstorm amphibious fishes
use powerful fins to move on land and
clever tools
to navigate as they go the gnopoli rock
climbing gobi
no bigger than a few centimeters scales
hundred meter tall
hawaiian waterfalls inching its way up
by alternately attaching the suction
cups on its mouth
and pelvic fins to find water while on
land
the mumma chog like most amphibious
fishes
is on the lookout for reflective
surfaces
other species like mosquito fish
exercise their
inner ear to determine where they're
oriented on a slope
relying on the probability that they'll
find water
by moving downhill our walking catfish
meanwhile
uses the taste buds that coat its body
for navigation these taste buds are
concentrated in its whiskers
which whip through the air sensing
compounds
that signal the proximity and quality of
nearby water and prey the walking
catfish will shimmy towards
attractive volatile amino acids
while steering clear of foul waters
emanating hydrogen sulfide
while amphibious fishes face a multitude
of new challenges upon leaving the water
they've evolved ingenious ways to
overcome them
they're resilient in the face of
droughts and floods
and have access to new prey as well as a
plan
b if they need to escape competitive
polluted
or unhealthy environments while being a
fish out of water is generally regarded
as a bad thing
for these species it offers an
undisputed
edge
would you rather be able to smell a drop
of blood from hundreds of meters away
or generate your own electricity
choose your fish superpower with one of
these videos